today we're doing something different
our friend john green will read a story
from his podcast the anthropocene
reviewed we hope you enjoy it and we'll
be back with a regular video
soon
so if you've ever been or had a child
you will likely already be familiar with
hand stencils they were the first
figurative art made by both our kids
somewhere between the ages of two and
three my children spread the fingers of
one hand out across a piece of paper and
then with the help of a parent traced
their five fingers
i remember my son's face as he lifted
his hand and looked absolutely shocked
to see the shape of his hand
still on the paper
a semi-permanent record of himself
i am extremely happy that my children
are no longer three and yet to look at
their little hands from those early
artworks is to be inundated with a
strange soul-splitting joy
those pictures remind me that they are
not just growing up but also growing
away from me
running toward their own lives
but of course that's meaning i am
applying to their hand stencils and that
complicated relationship between art and
its viewers is never more fraught than
when we are looking deeply into the past
in september of 1940 an 18 year old
mechanic named marcel ravidat was
walking his dog robot in the countryside
of southwestern france when the dog
disappeared down a hole
robot eventually returned but the next
day ravidat went to the spot with three
friends to explore the hole
and after quite a bit of digging they
discovered a cave with walls covered
with paintings including over 900
paintings of animals horses stags bison
and also species that are now extinct
including a wooly rhinoceros the
paintings were astonishingly detailed
and vivid with red yellow and black
paint made from pulverized mineral
pigments that were usually blown through
a narrow tube possibly a hollowed bone
onto the walls of the cave
it would eventually be established that
these artworks were at least 17 000
years old
two of the boys who visited the cave
that day were so profoundly moved by the
art they saw
that they camped outside the cave to
protect it
for over a year
after world war ii the french government
took over protection of the site and the
cave was opened to the public in 1948
when picasso saw the cave paintings on a
visit that year he reportedly said
we have invented nothing
there are many mysteries at lesko why
for instance are there no paintings of
reindeer which we know were the primary
source of food for the paleolithic
humans who lived in that cave why were
they so much more focused on painting
animals than painting human forms why
are certain areas of the cave filled
with images including pictures on the
ceiling that required the building of
scaffolding to create while other areas
have only a few paintings and were the
paintings spiritual here are our sacred
animals or were they practical here is a
guide to some of the animals that might
kill you
aside from the animals there are nearly
a thousand abstract signs and shapes we
cannot interpret and also several
negative hand stencils as they are known
by art historians these are the
paintings that most interest me
they were created by pressing one hand
with fingers splayed against the wall of
the cave and then blowing pigment
leaving the area around the hand painted
similar hand stencils have been found in
caves around the world from indonesia to
spain to australia to the americas to
africa we have found these memories of
hands from 15 or 30 or even 40 000 years
ago
these hand stencils remind us of how
different life was in the distant past
amputations likely from frostbite are
common in europe and so you often see
negative hand stencils with three or
four fingers and life was short and
difficult as many as a quarter of women
died in childbirth around 50
of children died before the age of five
but they also remind us that the humans
of the past were as human as we are
their hands indistinguishable
from ours
these communities hunted and gathered
and there were no large caloric
surpluses so every healthy person would
have had to contribute to the
acquisition of food and water
and yet somehow
they still made time to create art
almost as if art isn't optional for
humans
we see all kinds of hands stenciled on
cave walls children and adults but
almost always the fingers are spread
like my kids hand stencils
i'm no jungian but it's fascinating and
a little strange that so many
paleolithic humans who couldn't possibly
have had any contact with each other
created the same paintings the same way
paintings that we are still making
but then again what the lasko art means
to me is likely very different from what
it meant to the people who made it
some academics theorized that the hand
stencils were part of hunting rituals
then there's always the possibility that
the hand was just a convenient model
situated at the end of the wrist
to me though the hand stencils at lesco
say
i was here
they say
you are not new
and because they are negative prints
surrounded by red pigment
they also look to me like something out
of a horror movie like ghostly hands
reaching up from some bloody background
they remind me that as alice walker
wrote
all history is current
the lasco cave has been closed to the
public for many years now too many
contemporary humans breathing inside of
it led to the growth of mold and lichens
which has damaged some of the art
just the act of looking at something can
ruin it i guess
but tourists can still visit an
imitation cave called glasgow 2
in which the artwork has been
meticulously recreated
humans making fake cave art to save real
cave art may feel like peak anthropocene
behavior
but i have to confess that even though i
am a jaded and cynical semi-professional
reviewer of human activity i actually
find it overwhelmingly hopeful that four
teenagers and a dog named robot
discovered a cave with seventeen
thousand-year-old handprints that the
cave was so overwhelmingly beautiful
that two of those teenagers devoted
themselves to its protection
and that when we humans became a danger
to that cave's beauty we agreed to stop
going
lasko is there
you cannot visit
you can go to the fake cave we've built
and see nearly identical hand stencils
but you will know
this is not the thing itself
but a shadow of it
this is a hand print
but not a hand
this is a memory that you cannot return
to
all of which makes the cave very much
like the past it represents
we hope you enjoyed this video even if
it was different check out john green's
podcast the anthropocene reviewed where
he poetically reviews the human world we
live in
john is a good friend of course gazart
in fact without his channel crash course
that he and his brother hank started
years ago kurtzgazzard would not exist
because it was the original inspiration
for what we do today
and over the years john and hank have
helped us in a multitude of ways from
advice to just being friends so check
out the anthropocene reviewed or any of
their many channels
[Music]
you